As you know India is a land of about 1.3 billion people,
has a big demographic divide
with people of multiple income levels,
multiple literacy levels, multiple languages.
What technology can do is to create a common layer
and can actually improve the quality of life of people.
I think the greatest tool we have today in front of us is the smartphone.
And, there's a hell of a lot of things you can do with that
and real world problems you can solve with that.
A mobile phone along with an internet connectivity
just makes everybody stand at the same level.
HealthifyMe is India's largest health and fitness app.
Slowly but surely, an app a day we are keeping
the health momentum and revolution going in the country.
There were no calorie counting tools for this country.
And we are the diabetic and heart problems capital of the world.
And I felt that’s a problem of hundreds of millions of Indians
and someone had to build Indian nutritional database.
UrbanClap is an app which helps you
buy very high quality and trusted home services
everything from a beautician to an interior designer
and everything else in the middle.
If you look at the service professional ecosystem in India,
the vast majority of these people,
even though they're good at their craft,
make ten to fifteen thousand rupees a month.
And multiple reasons hinder them from becoming
a fully organised micro-service entrepreneur
who can make forty/ fifty/ sixty thousand rupees a month
and be a real part of India's middle class.
RailYatri is about helping travellers in India
who use railways as a mode of transportation
to make smart decisions.
We have gotten used to tracking an envelope
going from one part of the country to the other part of the world,
why can't we track about half a kilometre long train?
We clearly knew that people use
language for content consumption.
If you look at the readership of newspapers,
if you look at the readership of Bollywood movies,
I mean, they are all in local languages.
So, that came intuitively
rather than any market research done around it,
we intuitively thought about that as a core pivot and
a core reason why people will use our app.
DailyHunt app is one of the most popular apps in the country.
95% of our consumption is in local languages which is non-English.
Today the app is used by three million users everywhere.
We have got nearly 200 coaches and nutritionists
spread all over the country
and our app is one of the highest rated apps in India.
On a monthly basis, we are reaching to about nine million people.
Over a period of time now, we have added
all the routes, hospitals, information and all.
We have about seventy thousand service partners,
who use our app literally every single day.
We continue to serve more than ten thousand customers every single day.
We want to create a million jobs in the service sector in India.
I think my suggestion to everybody
who is thinking about doing something of their own
is don't be scared.
Nobody to the best of my knowledge, has died of entrepreneurship.
If you've got a great idea, just keep at it!
You need to get out of your offices
and go into the real Bharat in India
if you really want to build an app
which has to be successful in India.